avec nous en direct merci beaucoup
François Bayrou maire de Pau président
du MoDem au commissaire au Plan et
évidemment pilier de la majorité
présidentielle on va en parler dans un
instant vous avez un jouet un rôle clé
dans les dernières heures dans les
derniers jours dans le l'évolution de
cette crise on entendra aussi vos vos
conseils et vous pronostics mais s'il
vous plaît d'abord peut-être votre
commentaire sur les images que nous
découvrons ensemble en direct
bon ce sont des images qui évidemment
sont très troublantes et en fait
inacceptables
mais il n'acceptable pour une raison que
personne ne dit c'est que ceux qui
manifestent se sont les principales
victimes s'il n'y a pas de réforme des
retraites
ce que Qui qui
crie des slogans ou ceux qui participent
à ces échauffourés c'est eux qui
paieront
c'est ces jeunes là ce sont les jeunes
actifs et les plus jeunes parmi les
actifs qui vont devoir porter la dette
insupportable
qu'on fait grandir chaque année pour
ajouter
pour compenser le déficit des retraites
en France on parlera parce que ça
personne ne le dit
on parlera effectivement très en détail
de cette question de fond c'est à dire
ce qui est en train de se passer pour
cette génération qui manifeste on le
disait tout à l'heure beaucoup ont une
vingtaine d'années et pour les suivantes
mais on s'attardant à l'instant encore
sur sur cet événement même quel est
selon vous le risque de l'incontable
l'un contre l'autre ici à Paris mais
aussi on va l'évoquer à Lyon à Toulon à
Bordeaux ou ce genre d'événement ont
lieu
je pense que les forces de l'ordre ont
fait ces dernières années des progrès
considérables
et qu'il faut saluer et souligner
ce que ce qu'ils ont
organisé comme progrès pour avoir la
maîtrise de ce genre
d'accidents de foule ou de risque
d'accidents de foule ça mérite un coup
de chapeau et le
les réunions qui ont été organisées les
progrès sans cesse maintenus les études
parfois extrêmement poussés et
scientifique qui sont faites et
le et le préfet de police y participe et
tous les syndicats vous avez entendu
monsieur Joron c'est les syndicats sont
partis prenantes de cette maîtrise du
risque et ça passe par le respect des
manifestants
éviter les affrontements évitez la
confrontation évitez la violence et les
chocs est-ce que et ça mérite un coup de
chapeau est-ce que cependant il faudra
être ferme dès lors qu'il s'agit d'un
blocage possible mise de l'Intérieur
disait ni bordélisation nialisation ce
sont ces termes est-ce que dès lors
qu'on parle des raffineries qu'on parle
vraiment de l'alimentation nécessaire du
pays il faut être plus ferme
il n'y a pas une société dans le monde
qui puisse survivre au désordre absolu
que certains mouvements certaines
tendances voudraient créer et faire
flamber il n'y a pas une société dans
laquelle on puisse étudier travailler
projeter son avenir si on est dans la
violence si on est dans le fait que on
fait on fait flamber les choses ou si on
est dans le fait que par exemple les
poubelles ne sont plus relevées et que
s'entassent plus de 10000 tonnes de
poubelles avec tous les risques
sanitaires que cela comporte il est
temps d'y remédier pardon c'est le fait
le plus anecdotique mais évidemment ça
frappe en France et dans le monde entier
ces images des poubelles dans Paris
elles ont une partie brûler maintenant
mais pour vous il est temps maintenant
là immédiatement dire
il est temps depuis plusieurs jours le
le fait que qu'on se satisface de cette
espèce de dérive qui fait que la
capitale de la France la ville lumière
la ville vers laquelle qu'on verge tant
et tant d'habitants de la planète pour
découvrir quelque chose de grand et de
beau et que ce soit ens le enseveli sous
les détritus c'est insupportable avec
tout ce que ça fait courir comme risque
que nous savons de de
sanitaire et de rats enfin tout ce que
l'imaginaire collectif met sous des
morceaux de poubelles qui ne sont pas
relevées
et je vais laissez-moi finir la phrase
pardon je voudrais je voudrais vous dire
pourquoi on ne peut pas vivre comme ça
parce que ceux qui trinquent ce sont les
plus pauvres
c'est ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'avoir des résidences
d'avoir de beaux appartements et qui ont
seulement leur ville pour pour être fier
et pour avoir de la beauté autour d'eux
pour découvrir
ce que
les perspectives sublimes que des
Haussmann ont mis en place c'est eux les
pauvres qui sont les victimes et qui
trinquent on dit qu'on se bat en leur
nom on se bat contre leur vie et leur
cadre de vie et donc oui pour moi c'est
inacceptable et c'est pourquoi la
sécurité et le premier des droits de
l'homme
vous avez dit tout à l'heure certains
ont encouragé assez assez désordres qui
politiquement responsable de cela
non j'ai aucune envie de jouer au jeu de
c'est la faute des autres je trouve
qu'en France le
Light motiv c'est la faute des autres
quand on est dans un camp on pense que
c'est la faute des autres de l'autre
camp est réciproquement et moi je ne
veux pas être dans un camp je veux
chaque fois que nécessaire si je peux si
nous avons la force morale nécessaire je
veux défendre le le
bien le patrimoine commun que nous
construisons ensemble et donc j'ai
aucune envie de mener des procès contre
les angles alors les autres alors j'ai
des idées j'ai les yeux ouverts je suis
pas totalement stupide mais je n'ai pas
envie de de d'être procureur alors c'est
très loi le met alors François Bayrou si
vous voulez pas parler de la faute des
autres est-ce qu'il y a une part de
fautes dans votre propre camp le 49-3 il
est dans la Constitution c'est pas un
putsch on l'a bien compris mais le fait
qu'il soit ressenti de cette manière
est-ce que ça n'a pas été sous-estimé
par votre propre camp
pas du tout mais ce qui a ce qui a été
une insuffisance c'est qu'on n'a pas
réussi ou qu'on n'a pas su
partager avec les Français
les raisons qui font que cette réforme
et je pèse mes mots pardonnez-moi de le
faire que cette réforme est vitale c'est
à dire que ce que nous jouons là c'est
l'essentiel ou une part essentielle de
notre avenir pourquoi cette réforme est
vitale je reprends les chiffres et je
vous embêterai pas longtemps avec les
chiffres
les pensions de retraite le coût des
pensions de retraite c'est
345 milliards
faut rappeler que 1 milliard c'est mille
millions d'euros
345 milliards sur ces 345 milliards les
employeurs les employeurs du privé comme
du public
en paix en assume de 170 milliards et
tout le reste c'est l'état
l'État pour deux fonctions principales
la première il compense les sacrifices
ou les aides ou les coups de pouce
qu'ils demandent aux caisses de retraite
et deuxièmement il compense les déficits
des régimes de retraite et il les
compense à hauteur de 30 ou 40 milliards
d'euros tous les ans depuis 20 ans
François bayrouard dont je vous
interrompre
le risque qu'il n'est pas à long terme
seulement il serait là immédiat ces
prochaines années
immédiat pas ces prochaines années les
années actuelles et je suis moi
estomaqué stupéfait et
j'écarquille les yeux devant le fait que
on ne le dise pas on cache ça on a caché
ça j'ai
édité une une analyse du plan qui a
établi tous ces chiffres et ils n'ont
été contestés par personne donc tous les
ans pour compenser les déficits des
régimes de retraite on apporte entre 30
et 40 milliards 30 et 40 000 millions
d'euros tous les ans cet argent si on
l'avait
on serait tout à fait libre de le donner
aux caisses de retraite
mais nous ne l'avons pas cet argent nous
l'empruntons
tous les ans donc François
de la République et ceux qui manifestent
en ce moment à la compréhension le mot
et d'autres camarades on dit qu'Emmanuel
Macron a dit que il fallait absolument
la réforme coûte que coûte sans quoi il
y avait un risque financier et
économique et on interprète souvent ça
en disant mais c'est les marchés qui
risqueraient de mal réagir vous dites le
risque est encore plus grand il est
notamment du fait de la hausse des taux
immédiat
mais la hausse des taux vous le savez
bien vous l'avez répété ces jours-ci
plusieurs fois sur votre antenne je vous
ai entendu monsieur Rochebin la hausse
des taux elle est en cours et donc
accumuler les dizaines de milliards de
dettes sur le dos de ceux qui les
paieront c'est à dire les plus jeunes
c'est immoral c'est inacceptable c'est
condamnable de toute de toutes les
manières on imagine pas des parents et
des grands-parents qui se feraient payer
par des chèques par leurs enfants ou
leurs petits-enfants leur
retraite leur
ressources personne ne peut imaginer ça
c'est ce que nous faisons tout le temps
et ce que le et le crève-cœur pour moi
c'est qu'on a pas réussi à le faire
entendre alors François mais on n'a pas
essayons aidez-nous à comprendre
pourquoi ça s'est mal passé pour
l'instant on verra la suite on verra la
motion censure et on va en reparler mais
pour bien décortiquer ce qui s'est
produit vous non seulement un acteur
mais à la fois témoin puisque vous étiez
dans ces réunions cruciales auprès
d'autres responsables de la majorité au
président de la auprès du président de
la République quand la décision a été
prise d'aller au 49-3 est-ce que c'est
vrai d'abord que vous n'étiez pas de cet
avis que vous auriez préféré aller au
vote non j'aurai j'aurais préféré je
l'ai beaucoup expliqué qu'on vote mais
dans les circonstances où nous étions
hier
j'estime qu'il n'y avait pas d'autres
choix parce que
en fait c'est des petites affaires
politiciennes de de politique
parlementaire de de couloir de
discussion
le gouvernement a cru
et la majorité accrue pendant très
longtemps
moi j'y croyais pas trop mais la
majorité a cru pendant très longtemps
qu'elle allait recevoir le soutien d'une
partie des oppositions qui allaient
apporter leur suffrage et leur vote pour
que la réforme puisse se réaliser en
particulier dès moi j'étais plus
sceptique par oui mais je veux je veux
pas désigner les uns les autres mais
c'est vrai pas vrai on prend pas
beaucoup de risques pour l'essentiel
voilà et donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
par nos François Bayrou parce que c'est
pas seulement de la curiosité attendez
attendez c'est pas souvent la curiosité
quand on cancanir c'est quand même
pardon on parle d'une des plus grandes
réformes emblématiques pour le
quinquennat pour cette génération est-ce
que le Président de la République est-ce
que Madame borne ont surestimé la
fiabilité de CLR qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé exactement est-ce qu'ils étaient
pas fiables et ce qu'ils ne tenait pas
leur troupes qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
je crois qu'il y a eu dans la majorité
dans l'exécutif comme une illusion
illusion à laquelle vous savez bien j'ai
pas participé parce que quand quelqu'un
j'essaie de parler avec respect y
compris de mes adversaires pour essayer
de comprendre ce qui se passe dans leur
esprit quand quelqu'un a été élu dans
l'opposition c'est très difficile qu'il
apparaisse comme le comme le sauveteur
de la majorité je crois que de bonnes
foi un certain nombre était prêt à le
faire mais leur nombre s'est avéré hier
insuffisant pour arriver à un résultat
garanti et c'est cette découverte que au
fond
on a vécu
à des à une situation plus favorable ou
qu'on avait fait croire à une situation
plus favorable
cette découverte de du constat chiffré
qui a amené à une conclusion et la
conclusion est celle-ci s'il n'y avait
pas eu le 49.3 que je défendrai dans une
minute j'avertis le
oui ceux qui nous écoutent s'il n'y
avait pas eu le 49-3 hier soir jeudi
soir nous nous serions trouver avec plus
de projets de loi de réforme des
retraites il aurait été battu au vote et
plus de gouvernement puisque le
gouvernement était évidemment le tout
entier tourné vers la réforme des
retraites et de gouvernement aurait été
obligé vous dites bien de manière ou
d'une autre de s'en aller le
gouvernement a mal estimé la capacité de
soutien de CLR est-ce que il court le
risque là lors du vote de la motion de
censure d'aller à l'inconnu est-ce que
pour vous le risque existe pour le
gouvernement d'être renversé lundi
le risque existe toujours
ce sont des moments d'extrême tension
ce sont des moments qui sollicitent le
plus profond de l'engagement des
parlementaires des députés des trois
groupes de la majorité et des députés de
l'opposition qui vont devoir faire un
choix en conscience qui est un choix
extrêmement lourd
parce que cet article 49.3 de la
Constitution qu'on a pris l'habitude de
vilipender je ne sais pas pourquoi
peut-être je suis du naïveté confondante
mais je crois connaître assez bien les
institutions de la 5ème république
l'article 49 à l'ina3 de la Constitution
c'est une des clés de voûte de la
Cinquième République pourquoi qu'est-ce
qu'il dit cet article il dit quelque
chose de de d'absolument compréhensible
vous êtes le gouvernement et vous vous
avancez devant les Français et vous
dites écoutez le projet que je vous
propose et tellement important pour moi
que si vous n'en voulez pas il faut que
je m'en aille
si vous ne voulez pas si ce si le si
l'Assemblée nationale
refuse ce projet alors le gouvernement
est obligé de s'en aller mais il y a pas
plus démocratique il y a pas plus
sérieux il n'y a pas plus grave comme
vote que ce vote là ce qui disent les
oiseaux qui disent on va adopter un
texte sans vote c'est pas seulement un
vote c'est le vote le plus loin
si le gouvernement avait pu éviter dans
l'arrivée là il aurait évité donc c'est
bien qu'il y a quelque chose qui n'a pas
fonctionné
[Musique]
expliquez-nous je pose ma question
est-ce qu'il y a eu un manque disons de
de travail de capacité de savoir-faire
vous êtes mieux placé quiconque pour
dire que la politique c'est aussi du
salon un manque de savoir-faire en congé
de traiter de genoux la bonne je n'ai
pas du tout envie
je n'ai Darius Rochebin je n'ai pas du
tout envie de mener l'accusation contre
les uns ou contre les autres
j'étais comme comme vous savez assez
sceptique sur tout ça mais je veux vous
dire Michel Rocard le texte le plus
important qu'il a fait adopter c'était
la CSG la contribution sociale
généralisée c'est-à-dire le fait que on
allait transférer sur
l'impôt une partie des cotisations
sociales qui pesait trop lourd sur le
coup du travail par exemple
comment l'a-t-il fait adopter par le
49.3 j'étais député j'étais pas dans les
rangs de Michel Rocard et de la majorité
de l'époque qui n'avait pas de majorité
mais il y a des moments où c'est
si profond si grave si lourd que vous
faites passer votre esprit de préférence
partisane après l'intérêt général et
c'est je crois ce qui va se passer lundi
alors François
Bayrou si la motion de censure est
refusée d'abord est-ce que pour vous ça
reste l'hypothèse la plus crédible
oui bon mettons qu'elle soit refusée
est-ce que malgré tout on remaniement ce
profil est-ce que après une crise
pareille il serait logique sans
désabouler les personnes mais qui est
remaniement
alors permettez-moi de vous dire au cas
où vous en seriez pas aperçu que je ne
suis pas président de la République
c'est le président de la République qui
a cette responsabilité de de juger de la
situation et je puis vous assurer pour
m'arrive de parler avec lui de ces
sujets que c'est en profond de
conscience qu'il mesure
la situation de tension où nous sommes
et les risques encourus donc c'est lui
qui jugera
je me permets de nous interrompre
quand même politique ou il faut donner
un coup de sac quoi il faut redonner une
fraîcheur en élan à ce gouvernement
d'une manière ou d'une autre
vous voyez bien vous voyez bien qu'après
cette séquence il faudra ouvrir une page
nouvelle
le l'élection présidentielle c'était
focalisée sur la réforme des retraites
j'avais j'ai souvent exprimé que je
pensais que c'était pas le seul sujet
pour le pays c'est un sujet gravissime
pour la raison que je vous ai dit c'est
un sujet qui nous qui nous plonge dans
les extrêmes difficultés d'un pays qui
s'endette sans cesse pour simplement
assurer les dépenses quotidiennes c'est
n'importe quoi quand on s'endette faut
le faire pour construire des choses
importantes pour l'avenir pour faire des
investissements pour construire des
hôpitaux des universités des centres de
recherche
on parlait ici de la politique au sens
tout à fait noble mais incarner est-ce
que Madame borne peut rester première
ministre après ça
c'est le choix qu'elle fera et que fera
le président de la République elle a dit
hier quelque chose qui a été rapporté
par les journaux et qui est vrai elle a
dit que son intention n'était pas de
maître son cas particulier dans le la
balance
quelle était prête à encourir les
risques au nom de l'ensemble de la
majorité et comme vous avez vu elle l'a
fait courageusement devant l'Assemblée
déchaînée les hurlements faut savoir que
c'était à un point tel que les députés
qui étaient dans l'hémicycle n'ont pas
entendu le discours de la première
ministre vous nous et nous nous avons
entendu
grâce à vos micros qui sont savamment
réglés pour à moindrir le son de
l'hémicycle et rendre plus présent le
son du micro de l'orateur mais les
députés dans la salle j'allais dire les
pauvres députés qui sont qui vivent tout
ça comme
quelque chose de déshonorant et qui en
sont profondément blessés les
témoignages sont innombrables ce que ce
que je reçois qui disent mais c'est pas
possible de continuer comme ça il y a là
quelque chose qui nous
déshonore comme représentant du peuple
il y a aussi pardon
il y a aussi les députés soit du RN qui
ne pense pas ça soit surtout de la
France insoumise qui ne pense pas ça et
c'est eux précisément qui chantait la
Marseillaise quel jugement vous portez
sur eux
bon ils ont choisi un mode de
déstabilisation
quelqu'un employait le mot de ZAD c'est
quelque chose de cet ordre ils ont
choisi la déstabilisation maximale pour
empêcher l'exercice normal du pouvoir je
pense qu'il se trompe profondément pour
notre démocratie pour notre notre vie en
commun mais c'est ce qu'ils ont choisi
et c'est ce qu'ils sont en train de
faire et le
et la majorité des députés de
l'Assemblée nationale vit cela comme une
perte de sens ils disent mais à quoi ça
sert qu'on soit là dans cette espèce de
perpétuel Charivari François en dehors
en dehors même pardon
en dehors même de l'Assemblée nationale
tout à l'heure c'est ce que nous envoies
spéciaux qui le disait on a brûlé des
effigies en carton d'Emmanuel Macron ça
rappelle pendant la crise précédente
notamment Emmanuel Macron qui avait été
en effigie décapité comment est-ce que
vous jugez ce genre de représentation
vous savez bien je la juge comme vous et
comme tous ceux qui la plupart de ceux
qui nous écoutent c'est
attristan au point d'en être inquiétant
le
fait que qu'on joue avec des effigies
pour leur faire subir les tortures et
les supplisses sont très mauvais signal
pour un pays pourquoi parce qu'il y a
des enfants il y a des gosses qui voient
ça et qui après tout finissent par
s'habituer à ce genre de comportement
violent et donc pour moi évidemment de
vous n'attendiez pas une autre réponse
je trouve que c'est très mauvais signe
sur sur
l'évolution de notre état d'esprit en
tant que pays vous incarnez nous soyons
capables vous incarner et si nous ne
sommes pas capables de corriger ça alors
nous allons rencontrer de très graves
accidents comme pays comme nation est-ce
que c'est le moment que
c'est le moment que le vieux monde
politique reprenne un peu la main quand
on voit que le gouvernement de fait
rater une partie de son cours c'est la
presse internationale est très sévère
sur ce qui s'est passé et il y a pas
besoin d'être de toute façon très
objective évidemment s'il y avait pas eu
de 49-3 ça aurait été mieux pour vous
est-ce que c'est le moment de revenir un
certain savoir-faire politique qu'on a
beaucoup peuplé le vieux monde
oui mais que je n'ai jamais appelé le
vieux monde d'abord parce que sans doute
j'ai fait un long bout de chemin avec ce
monde-là et qu'il y avait des
personnalités politiques de de ayant un
très grand sens des responsabilités et
de très grandes cultures
démocratiques ça c'est perdu c'est une
c'est une respiration c'est oui bien sûr
c'est l'accident de enfin c'est comme ça
que ça s'est passé mais c'est une
respiration il y a des moments où les
peuples ont besoin de renouveau et de
jeunesse et puis il y a des moments où
ils ont besoin d'expérience
alors si on pouvait avoir la jeunesse et
l'expérience en même temps
malheureusement c'est très peu souvent
le cas et donc je oui je sais que dans
beaucoup d'esprits aujourd'hui il y a
l'idée que
[Musique]
tout ça n'est pas à la hauteur
dans beaucoup d'esprits il y a l'idée
que qu'on peut pas s'accommoder de
[Musique]
d'accepter
de baisser les bras et qui va falloir
donner au pays partagé avec les Français
responsabilités que le Président de la
République va devoir exercer partager
avec les Français une autre vision de
l'avenir et au fond une autre hiérarchie
des valeurs qui nous font vivre ensemble
vous savez que c'est une question de
personne aussi c'est un secret de
polichinelle que vous étiez assez
critique lors de la nomination de Madame
borne est-ce que en termes de personnes
cela doit jouer vous même est-ce que
vous êtes candidat Premier ministre
non
[Musique]
cette cette présentation là si vous
croyez que je viens à votre micro et que
nous avons
duplex aussi important depuis depuis
pour depuis les Pyrénées pour pour faire
acte de candidature à une fonction alors
c'est que vous avez pas compris où j'en
suis aujourd'hui
je
n'ai pas de carrière je n'ai pas de
souci de carrière probablement j'en ai
eu comme tout le monde
mais aujourd'hui je suis devant le
spectacle d'un pays qui s'abandonne
et qui a le sentiment d'être abandonné
d'être abandonné par tous les cadres
qu'il avait fait confiance je parle pas
des personnalités mais les cadres du
pays la loi la Constitution
parlementaire
au fond vous dites un pays qui
s'abandonne on va on va parler dans un
instant de la Chine des États-Unis de la
grande compétition mondiale ce pays qui
à taureau a raison ne veut pas prolonger
le temps de travail dans est-ce que ça
n'est pas un pays qui ne veut plus jouer
la certaine carte d'une compétition
extrême encore une fois taureau a raison
que d'autres à notre place vont jouer
notamment les Chinois
bon c'est évidemment une question très
importante
et c'est probablement la question
en géopolitique en relation politique
entre les grands États et les États dans
le monde c'est la question que vous
dites
il n'y a pas de destin pour un pays s'il
n'est pas habité par cet élan vital
comme aurait dit un grand philosophe qui
s'appelait Bergson
habité par cet élan vital de vouloir
porter son destin au-delà même des
limites qui lui sont imposées
c'est le cas par exemple pour la
question de la démographie on parle de
la Chine la Chine et devant un drame
démographique la Chine dans les 30 ans
qui viennent va perdre écoutez bien
plusieurs centaines de millions
d'habitants
et va évidemment se trouver en situation
périlleuse du point de vue de
l'équilibre de la société qui est la
sienne
mais nous si nous n'acceptons pas de
poser la question démographique dans
notre pays du renouvellement des
générations du rôle nouvellement du du
travail de la recherche de l'invention
alors nous serons condamnés à être
déclassé perpétuellement c'est ce que
nous sommes en train de vivre c'est ce
que nous sommes en train alors on dit il
y a pas assez de sous il y a pas assez
de sous parce que nous n'avons pas
produit assez et si nous n'avons pas
produit assez c'est probablement parce
que nous n'avons pas instruit assez les
enfants et que nous avons toutes ces
crises imbriquées les unes dans les
autres que pour certains d'entre nous
nous avons non seulement vu venir mais
décrites mais multiplier les
avertissements si on ne s'attaque pas à
ça alors il est sûr que le destin de la
France sera de voir disparaître son
étoile ensoleillant on parle de la de la
France en général de son destin dans le
système de la 5ème république tout vient
au président de la République
tout lui revient la personne d'Emmanuel
Macron vous disiez c'est pas la faute à
X ou à y tout lui reviendra de toute
façon qu'est-ce qui a manqué au
président de la République pour arriver
à cette situation là qui visiblement
n'est pas celle que lui-même souhaitait
et encore quelques jours
[Musique]
je pense qu'il y a eu une
un moment d'incompréhension et les
gilets jaunes ont été une étape très
importante de ce moment
d'incompréhension là et le président de
la République avait pas passé un contrat
avec le pays qui est de renouveler
profondément
le pouvoir
ses habitudes ces attitudes et le lien
avec les Français
il a fait sur un certain nombre de
sujets
au sclérose de la haute fonction
publique il s'est attaqué
comme on dit à ce qu'il y avait de
complètement bloqué dans dans un certain
nombre de corps
il sait il a fait ses efforts là mais
François
gilet jaune quand on voit ce qui se
passe ce soir à la Concorde quand on
voit ce qui se passe à Toulon à Bordeaux
à Lyon est-ce que c'est le grand spectre
est-ce que vous allez devoir céder si
demain ça prend cet ampleur là si demain
il y a un mort si demain il y a des
blessés
je ne crois je ne crois pas et je n'en
crois rien et ce s'il y avait ce
mouvement de dérive et de démission ça
serait une catastrophe formidable comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de vous l'expliquer
pour les plus jeunes des Français les
victimes ceux qui portent sur le front
la pancarte des victimes certaines à
venir et qu'on fait ou qui défilent de
bonne foi en croyant qu'au contraire ils
vont défendre leurs avantages et leur
liberté c'est là la tragédie de ce
mouvement
c'est un c'est un quiproquo tragique et
donc le je suis certain que l'intérêt du
pays
commande n'ont pas contiennent bon mais
qu'on soit capable de porter jusqu'à
leur terme des décisions et des prises
de conscience et vous me demandez
qu'est-ce qui manque le plus ce qui
manque le plus c'est la prise de
conscience ce qui manque le plus c'est
que chez nous dans nos familles autour
de la table de famille avec nos amis
nous disions bon quand même alors c'est
pas exactement ce qu'on souhaite c'est
pas forcément les gens qu'on
souhaiterait exactement mais nous ne
pouvons pas rester sans rien faire en
face de situations aussi ou
compromettante que celle-là merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité merci
beaucoup en direct depuis merci à vous
et nous allons retrouver